What's up Psych2Go viewers my name is Donna
and our first story comes from the Video Gaming
World.
Remember when we had some researchers saying
that violent video games creates violent kids
and then we had another group of researchers
saying no no no no.
Then they started to argue and there was this
whole clash.
Well we've got some new research on the situation,
but before we jump right into the news I'd
like to thank our sponsor Best Fiends.
Best Fiends is a puzzle adventure game where
you collect a team of fiends to defeat slugs
by matching same colored objects.
It's pretty addicting.
I'm already on level 42.
If you play or want to play, let me know what
level you're on.
This month they're doing an Easter Egg challenge
where you can win amazing and rare rewards.
If you beat all 16 challenges, you win a new
bunny character and who doesn't like bunnies?
you can download the game free.
I'll link it down in the description and as
a bonus you'll get five dollars worth of gold
and diamonds for free...in the game of course.
Back to the news.
Ever since the emergence of violent TV shows,
movies, and now video games the topic of those
things causing aggression has been hotly debated.
A majority of studies have found violent video
games to be linked to increased aggression
and decreased empathy.
There's just one problem, a majority of those
studies were focused on short term results.
This means past studies typically had someone
play a violent video game and right after
the game's done researchers would test aggression
and empathy levels.
What do you know?
Aggression levels were up and empathy levels
were lower.
But here's the thing those same results can
be found after any competitive or frustrating
task, whether that be not being able to solve
a math problem or not being able to pass level
40 of Best Fiends.
Because of this researchers in Germany decided
to test for long term effects.
Instead of requiring participants to play
games like in past studies scientists recruited
people who already regular played violent
video games and people who don't play video
games.
Gamers and non-gamers were then shown a series
of images that would evoke some sort of emotional
response.
For example, according to past studies this
image would not move a gamer as much as a
non-gamer.
Once shown the images neural responses were
examined via Fmri results show both groups
having the same level of empathy contrary
to previous studies.
Our last study comes from the Massachusetts
institute of technology where scientists have
developed an AI system that can detect a conversation's
tone.
So how this works is that users wear this
watch like device.
The device analyzes audio, text transcriptions,
and physiological signs.
For example, more sad and negative conversations
are usually associated with more pauses, monotonous
vocal tones, and increased cardio vascular
activities.
The device takes record of this and is able
to classify the emotional tone of a conversation
with 83% accuracy.
Now they researchers of this system claim
its most use for those who need some sort
of social coach.
People with Aspergers or anxiety but imagine
how conversations would be if everyone had
a watch like this.
That's all the news we have for you today.
I hope you enjoyed it.
We at Psych2Go would like to know your opinions
and what you learned today.
Do you think violent video games causes increased
aggression?
What do you think about this new device?
I'll see you guys next time.